[Musique]
et bien cette soirée s'achève alors
avant de nous séparer juste un petit
coup d'œil sur la soirée de demain des
20h35 nous retrouvons bien sûr jean-
richichard le commissaire maigré dans
une toute nouvelle enquête intitulée
maigré à Vichy et juste après aux
alentours de 22h15 dans music haw cur en
compagnie d'EM Reri et bien nous
partirons à la recherche de Stravinski
un merveilleux compte musical inspiré
des musiques du compositeur russe à la
recherche de S et dans Musique au cœur
de massoir et et puis il y a un nouveau
rendez-vous sur lequel j'aimerais
attirer votre attention à partir de
demain chaque dimanche à 9h et bien nous
suivrons les émissions religieuses
connaître l'islam la source de vie
présence protestante le jour du Seigneur
et la messe et la messe notée dès
maintenant elle sera célébrer demain
avec la paroisse Saint-Pierre Saint-Paul
de rueeille Malmaison en raison donc des
émissions religieuses le premier
rendez-vous de la journée avec Jacques
Martin sera un petit peu reculé nous
retrouvons donc Jacques Martin et toute
l'équipe d'entré les artistes de ain aux
alentours de midi pour l'instant je vous
souhaite à tous et à toutes de passer
une excellente fin de soirée une très
belle nuit et notre prochain rendez-vous
et bien c'est demain matin à 8h30 avec
le flash information mais aussi avec les
chevaux du tiercé
[Musique]
bonsoir